[Music]
Kelly you are GameSpot's resident
Pokemon expert so I brought you in here
to break down the reveal trailer for
pokemons sword and shield which looks
like they're taking place in something
similar to the UK yeah so I think the
surface level takeaways are you know we
got titles for the first time the game
was first announced back at e3 2017
we've been waiting for a long time for
titles which is not that not what I
expected so a new shield that goes with
what we see of the region which I think
a lot of people now are just assuming to
be inspired by the UK seems very British
the deeper you go into the trailer other
things we see the return of typical
battle style or like catching mechanics
random encounters random encounters yeah
you don't see Pokemon in the overworld
really in this trailer and you don't see
Pokemon you know following your player
character we don't see anything about
ride Pokemon for example which is one
thing that I really hope returns because
a chimes are dumb and we do see a train
in like a railway that goes through the
region
so that's likely to be some sort of fast
travel so a lot of smaller takeaways
that are a little hard to grasp when
you're just watching the trailer in full
so so what about the Pokemon we see the
Pokemon we see throughout this trailer
they're all returning Pokemon right
other than the starter is now starters
so there's like a battle montage later
in the trailer that goes pretty quickly
so I'll just lay out the Pokemon that
are in there Pikachu and VIN cheeto is
fighting Pikachu ysidro player character
huesemann Shino there's a very very
brief shot of wishy-washy and it took me
like seven tries to get a screenshot of
it grub in the little bug from Sun and
Moon hoot-hoot
Ellis who I love I'm really excited that
I get to train that dragon again Flygon
fighting what I'm almost certain as
brave iary wailmer fighting the female
form of meowstic which has different
colors for male and female
Lucario fighting Tyranitar and finally
outside of battle we see munchlax in
kind of a living room and then there is
one thing that we don't see the actual
Pokemon but at the very beginning
there's a shot of a weather vane that
looks like fletchling so I think it's
safe to assume that fletchling and that
evolutionary line would be in the game
and talonflame rules so that's
so that's so those are some surface
level things we noticed in the trailer
but you actually have some theories
you've dug deeper into this trailer
you've probably watched it like what 40
times by now a lot of times I watched on
half speed watch the Japanese when I
took it I took some time but given that
you've seen it so many times what are
some other little things that you've
noticed or maybe picked up on on reddit
or Twitter yeah so there's a one thing
that jumped out at me right away and I
actually wrote a story about it that you
can read on GameSpot and you can see the
screenshots there as well
but there's three instances of like a
stone like a big slab of stone with like
a weird symbol on it there's one of the
beginning that's in the foreground
overlooking a town there's one during
the sequence where they're showing a
Pokeball shaking and a Pokemon being
caught and then there's one later in the
trailer right in front of the gym it's
not any symbol that I recognize from
Pokemon but they seem kind of like
Celtic symbols and then there's another
thing I noticed which is a little bit
later in the trailer you see a hillside
like a carving of a figure a bipedal
figure that's not like a human
necessarily it kind of has like a beak
almost that would also point me to
Britain because Britain has those
there's like that famous horse carving
in the hillside and that to me is just
just screams legendary Pokemon not
exactly like any Pokemon that I know it
looks like it's breathing fire smoke and
also shooting out lightning at the same
time and then there's like people like
figures underneath it that seem to not
be having a great time with that yeah it
looks like they're dying it's pretty
intimidating actually I like how creepy
it is so that is something that I think
even more than the stones has a lot of
weight and Knight I think that'll come
into play it also shows just the scale
and the vistas you will see in this
which look amazing being able to get
that much depth and that much that much
of a world for a Pokemon game is really
exciting it's a lot bigger actually to
that point I mean I think one of the
concerns people have is the the map
seems pretty long and narrow it's kind
of like you'll just be going north the
whole time but if you look at what you
see in the trailer it seems a lot more
expansive than what
is represented in the map that we see
after the trailer has ended I think
that's not a one-to-one approximation of
how big the world is because you do see
like an expansive stretch of farm land
and the city seems very large and the
buildings are large so that's really
exciting and then I can go to Internet
theories because there are some good
ones that I I really want to talk about
snorlax monster on twitter has a a very
compelling not even a theory just
pointed out something very interesting
that we've seen the trailer so at the
very end you see the male trainer
character walking into a stadium wearing
some sort of sports uniform probably
soccer given that this is a UK and that
opens a lot of questions for me
but one thing Snorlax monster points out
is that on his sleeve there's a symbol
and it's like this red and blue swirl
symbol and the logos in Japanese have
that symbol on them in the writing for
Pokemon on the end character and that
isn't present in the English logo but
what's notable about that is that in
Pokemon Sun and Moon the Japanese logo
also had a symbol in that case it was a
crystal and Z crystals came into play in
battle in Sun and Moon so the theory
here is that this swirl logo has
something to do with a new battle
mechanic something with battle because
that hint was found in Sun and Moon
previously and Z crystals were a new
battle mechanic at that time so I think
that's really interesting
I don't know necessarily if it's a
battle mechanic or if that's the logo
for like whatever this soccer like
league is or whatever this stadium thing
is that would be really cool if it was
battle I'm definitely intrigued and I
really want to see what's up with that
and finally after the trailer they
showed a little teaser of the three
starters which is interesting because
normally they don't reveal them until
after they've been leaked right yeah a
lot of stories have been leaked in the
past yeah so this comes as like there's
like a it fades to black and then the
starters come in at the end of the
trailer there are three obviously GRU
key score Bunny and Sowell I'm still
getting used to the names but I like
Saab a whole lot let's start with GRU
key cuz I saw this is another reddit
post pointed out that groupies name in
English
be kind of ambiguous but if you look at
the French name it's least tempo I'm not
exactly sure how to pronounce it so
forgive me but tempo is in it and so the
theory is that group he has something to
do with music he bangs a little rock at
the beginning - yeah it was like a
sticker like I'm not even sure maybe
yeah twig that he sticks in his like
leaf fur Zabul I really like Sabha lat
first the first time we watched the
trailer a couple of us at work we're
like is that like a tadpole there's art
those you know there's already several
tadpole Pokemon but I think actually
it's a chameleon the trailer describes
it as a water lizard but you can see it
like is invisible in the water and
blending in and very shy and perfect and
I really am intrigued to see what the
final evolution for that is but I like
something it's something like whale you
know like because sob whale I was like
it wouldn't be a whale if it's a lizard
I gotcha
and then score bunny makes me nervous
because score bunny has the very cute
like bandage thing on its nose and
another bandage on its foot and I like
that look except it makes me worried
that square bunny is gonna be a fire
fighting type we already have plenty of
those we have fight chicken we have
fight pig we have fight monkey I I'm
just we don't need that anymore I know
I'm not alone in this I'm hoping that
square bunny is fire fairy because that
would provide interesting typing and
resistances especially the steel so
that's my sincerest hope and that the
bandage is just for for looks so who's
your starter then saw ball for sure
bobble I think savile is mine as well
but I really like GRU key I like all of
them actually and usually there's one
that I don't particularly like but I do
like all of these I just think Sabo I
just want subl to be happy and I want to
give it a hug kind of like pop leo
and I mean I am gonna wait and see what
the final evolutions are cuz like in Sun
and Moon I thought lit and was really
cute and I saw in sinner or and I was
like hell naw so yeah that's a wait and
see for me but I really do want to
protect savile with my whole heart thank
you all for tuning in pokemon sword and
shield is set to release in late 2019 if
you have any theories or hopes for the
next set of Pokemon games please let us
know in the comments and to no one's
surprise we're gonna continue covering
Pokemon so make sure to stay tuned to
games bot for all the news and updates